hi everyone my name is anush I'll be
speaking about tiling and parallel
processing of large imageries a little
introduction about me I'm a senior data
scientist at inteliner I mainly work on
computer vision
problems our company is an act tech
company we
work on making farming more data driven
we mostly work on
concern and corn soy and corn farms for
in the United States we get imageries
from airplane or satellite
providers and process those imageries to
find problem problematic areas in the
farms and make farming more data driven
um in average the stuff the farms in the
United States are around 600 acres that
would be around the same area that is
the city center of Yerevan which is
basically not a walking distance and
when you have grown corn that can be
higher than the average person in hate
so it's difficult to navigate there
that's why the need arises to have
aerial imageries in order to get a full
picture of the field and what is
happening there in general
um the main data that we use
currently about one pixel equals to 10
centimeters in resolution and covering
large distances we get pretty large
imagery so processing that takes a lot
of time and we stumble upon several
issues depending on what problem we're
solving main issues with processing
large imageries are of course that you
would first of all need a machine with a
large enough memory to be able to load
the entire thing and if you're doing
some Transformations etc etc be able to
keep all of that as well and
based on that of course this all also
takes quite a lot of time to do of
course it depends on the size of the
image you're processing and what exactly
you're doing but in our case it can take
up to a day to finish the whole process
from start to end so in this pipeline we
try to optimize as much of the processes
as possible so the solution we came to
is basically a dividend conquer one we
try to instead of solving a problem on
an entire image solve it on parts of the
image and then combine all of the
results together we can use rasterio to
read any sized tile from the image given
the exact coordinates where that portion
of the image is located so in the this
way we solve the problem of having to
load the entire thing at once we can
based on this as well do it in parallel
so we're again solving the problem of
time as well the issues now arise how do
we correctly combine the results
together so that we are as close to the
original as possible
the issues we've applied this approach
to are several we use it in
classification problems a segmentation
and even statistical calculations each
one done tile level is simple you just
do the same thing you would have done
for an entire image but you do it on a
smaller scale however the issues arise
when we're trying to combine the results
and for each of these problems the
solutions are different and the problems
will stumble upon are also quite
different
first off let's speak about
classification which is probably the
simplest one
um of these three let's say we want to
classify an image to be either a type 1
or type 2. instead of doing on the whole
thing we do it on the smaller scale and
then use Simple voting in this case we
have nine Parts uh three of them were
classified as type two six of them as
type 1 so the entire image would be
classified as type 1.
um in this case the only problem would
arise if we had the exact same number of
um
tiles be classified as type 1 and type
2. this can of course arise if you have
more classes as well
so what how would you classify in this
case
um in that for that purpose we keep also
the probabilities for each class for
each of the
separate sub sections of the image that
we're processing and in the end we just
average out the probabilities for each
in this case the it is highly unlikely
that you would end up with two classes
having the exact same probability which
is again unlikely but possible even if
you do any other classification model on
an imagery not just tile level as well
so this solves our problem for
classification and combining the results
style level so to summarize we just run
the same classification model on
separate tiles
save the results and the probabilities
of each class per tile and then average
out the probabilities to take the
maximum one
next we came into a problem to
um
be able to apply this to statistical
calculations
so basically this came from one case
which of course gave us a lot of
opportunities to improve for other
fields as well but the main issue was
with one just the field itself was so
large that just calculating
the standard deviation of the entire
data was taking
I think over 10 hours or something which
was crazy so we tried to
optimize that process
the calculations we came up to we needed
to do was min max average and standard
deviation for Min and Max it is fairly
simple you just take the Min and Max of
each and then take the mean of means Max
and Maxes and this will always be equal
no matter if you do it high level or do
it on the entire imagery you will have
no loss of accuracy whatsoever in this
case
um for me you have to do like one extra
step just keep the count of each data
point in each tile and then calculate
the mean based on that in this case
again you will have the exact same
average result if you do it high level
then combine or if you would have done
it
um separately however what do you do for
standard deviate deviation none of these
approaches or that you can come close
with averaging it out or doing something
else but it's still fairly far so I
found an approach to approximate
standard deviation you can see it on the
formula here we use the averages of each
tile the standard deviations of each
tile and it's as these are standard
deviation Mis are the means of each tile
and NIS are the number of points in each
tile
and on the previous example where we had
just four 15 data points I think the
standard original and estimated standard
deviations are almost identical however
if as I said our problems arise with
doing calculations on larger imageries
um doing this on larger scale the
difference is much more noticeable in
that case well it is more noticeable in
all the examples that we tried to decide
whether we want to move forward with
this example or not the most difference
we saw between the original and the
estimated was around two percent
um below is just an actual example from
one of our fields
to see the difference of estimated and
actual standard deviations and as we use
the statistical calculations to to later
in the feed decision trees we were okay
with having this type of small
variations because it is unlikely that
we would end up with two percent
difference that would push it to the
other branch of the tree so if this type
of
error time trade-off was okay for us and
for the example that I was telling you
about at the start of this section we
managed to speed up this whole
calculation process from 12 hours to 25
minutes doing guitar level
to summarize
again we do the calculation style level
we keep min max count of elements
standard deviation and average of each
tile and then use this to estimate
everything for the entire tiles
um another interesting question we came
up upon I think even last week actually
was how to do this same thing for
quantiles how can you estimate quantiles
of an entire image without having to
load the entire thing at once
um we actually found a couple approaches
for estimations these weren't as close
as the ones for standard deviations or
something else so I haven't really
included it but that's I think an
interesting thing to think about
segmentation
this can apply to any segmentation model
be it machine learning model that does
some the pixel wise
classification or something else the
thing We Came Upon when after needing
this was we needed to generate a map of
a given field and do it run time so
let's say for example here we on the
right left hand side we have the image
of a field on the right hand side we
have a generated map of the field with
four five classes I think this is done
if we
to do the same process on the entire
field currently our approach is that we
have to generate this map previously
keep the polygons that we have and then
when we have to generate this map of
instantly we just load the polygons and
do some final tweakings there however we
were thinking of a way that we can do
this more flexibly so that any change we
do we don't have to go back and we run
all of the flights to regenerate the
maps on all of the flights where we want
to have this map or be able to do quick
changes and see the results instantly
and stuff like that so the idea came to
try and do this tile level as well
let's say this example by the way is a
small example of the 10 24 pixels over
10 24 pixels just as a portion of a
field uh to so that I'll be able to show
all the details in this case we split it
into just four parts load each part
separately do the same map generation
algorithm that we did for the whole
thing and in this case as you can see we
have we have like clear lines clears
teaching lines that are clearly visible
like this is where the first Thailand
did this is where the second tile
started so
um how do we how are we able to make
this process smoother so we'll be able
to
end up with the map that actually looks
like a map not just several Maps
stitched together
um the idea is to instead of if we want
to see the 512 over 512 tile instead of
loading that we load it with a buffer so
that basically that tile is aware of
what is happening next to it what is
happening to its neighbor so we run the
same algorithm on a larger tile however
we still write the smaller one this
means that the first tile we will read
with a buffer
that is larger than itself the second
one is again we will read with an as an
overlap with the first one this means
that each of them is aware of all of the
neighbors that are beside them so the
transitions are able to be more smooth
in this case this is the result we see
again these are the same for tiles we
just read them with 50 pixels larger but
still around the 512 pixels over 512
pixels you can see here that we still
have some Distortion it is not
um ideal with smooth finish however this
is still better than the previous one
where we had them with exact lines
dividing each tile separately you can
again solve this problem by having a
larger overlap or doing some additional
smoothing etc for
um in the map generation process all
together
depends uh mostly on the problem you're
trying to solve however for us the
ability to be able to generate any map
from given any image instantly is more
um important than having a perfect map
even though it takes like 10 hours to
generate it for example
so to summarize here again we run the
segmentation model per tile
but with an additional buffer save the
results for from the original tile with
the smart smaller one combination is
just a raster IO gives you the option to
as I said read from each given tile from
each given location as well it gives the
option to write it and this gives us the
option to parallelize this process as
well
okay as a conclusion we can do tie level
processing in multiple scenarios this
goes for classification segmentation
even statistical calculations might be a
lot more scenarios that you may
encounter in your day-to-day life these
are the ones that we encountered and
were able to solve processing tile level
helps parallelize the process if you're
dealing with large imageries it
produces faster results
the results aren't always identical
whether you do it high level or do it on
the entire imagery the
way you could choose whether you want to
do the adapt this approach or multi is
how much you care about the accuracy of
your results and how much you care about
spending extra money or spending extra
time on your processing in our case we
have our entire process processing in on
AWS machines so we basically spend money
for every additional minute of
processing so being able to parallelize
a lot of stuff and do them faster is
important for us and giving a bit of
trade-off or accuracy is okay and in the
last approach as I already said this was
doing it this way was the fastest way to
be able to generate a map on the go for
any given image without needing any
additional information on that image
thank you
questions
is it the only application in uh
agricultural ecosystem or are there any
other use cases that these big data um
sourcing can be used there are other
companies that do sort of act Tech
stuff many are different of
there are some companies that provide
only imageries and do the processing on
those some companies that do the exact
zoning that I was showing I think
most of these use of satellite imageries
but a lot of people are trying to do the
same thing
are you using satellite images we're
using both starflight images and
airplane images depending on the area of
coverage airplane images fly lower so
you're getting better results there the
resolution is higher so you can see more
I just didn't think to put an example of
a field here but you can actually see
the vegetation rows because the
resolution is so high it's clearly
visible what's happening on the field
satellite imageries are lower resolution
more blurry but you can still get a lot
of value out of those
uh to calculate the statistics on
intensity speaks and intensities
yeah okay that's that's a good question
so um there's a vegetative index called
ndvi that is used in agriculture this is
the combination of Red Band and near
infrared band that we're able to get due
to our sensors
the idea is that you when combining
these two you get sort of a scale where
the brighter it is the more vegetation
there is the lower it is the less
vegetation there is you can clearly
identify vegetation roles there you just
go back this is just not colorized or
you would have been able to see better
however the brighter areas here are the
the darker areas here are the areas
where you have less vegetation this spot
here is actually just soil so you have
no vegetation there this sort of blurry
it looks blurry due to the resolution
but these are really clear of vegetation
Vine and the map we generate is based on
this as well which will give the farmer
general idea that this part of the field
has good vegetation this part has bad
vegetation and based on that map they
can actually load it into their
automated tractors and do some spraying
application or some other thing based on
the of geographic coordinates that we
are applying supplying
okay
can you go back to the slide where
you're showing the title logic
here here
so when you're living some part of the
main tile then how do you recover the
oh we're we're not leaving them we're
reading above them so basically this is
512 pixels instead of reading the 512
pixels we read like 560.
2 pixels so we have like 50 pixel buffer
here we do the segmentation on the
larger tile here but then we write the
smaller one if you would have robbed the
larger one you would have still gotten
like the line overlap that we saw on the
previous one however this way we're sort
of making them aware of what's happening
at its neighbor but then taking the
overlap and just
making sure that each of them is aware
of the of its of is responsible for its
own health
yeah we do the exact same so for the
first style you would read this 600
562 pixels for the next one you would
take 50 pixel buffer here and then also
50 pixel buffer here
on the right as well do you just resize
and put it on the other
well rasterio gives you the option to
use an offset so it does it for you you
just basically have to make sure that
when you're later on writing the tile
you just take the extra portions out
correctly and then write in its correct
location
okay so like and it seems to me that
there is something missing in those
areas where you make those 50 pixels we
don't leave anything out we we do in
with an overlap so you would read like a
larger portion here and then write the
small one read the larger portion here
right a small one they come and mixed
together at an exact same location so
when writing you don't overlap the two
tiles but when reading you read with an
overlap so they're aware of their
surroundings
the reason we don't write with an
overlap so you can have like small small
buffer when writing as well but it needs
to be smaller than the one you're
reading from otherwise you would have
like
so in this case we have no
um the
each tile doesn't know what's happening
around it so you have the it's the clear
lines dividing the two of mobs from each
other if we had like for example if we
read like this and wrote also the larger
one here there would still be some less
Distortion but more Distortion than if
you
um take out if you make sure that they
need in the middle and not overlap each
other when writing the tiles themselves
anything else
do you also try to change detection
like as I understand you monitor the
same place for a number of times yeah
you use some kind of
we do but probably not in the way you
might be thinking of so again for
um performances sake we don't
um the load two images from like two
different times in a timeline and try to
compare this I think we did that at some
point several years ago but we came to
the
um
our main product for analytics is to
generate some other trigger some alerts
like you have this issue here or this
issue there so the way we use change
detection is we generate prop candidate
problematic areas keep them as polygons
and not the entire image which is
um more efficient and easier to load as
well and afterwards of at some point in
the timeline when we try to identify if
an area is problematic we look at the
areas that overlapped with this one and
see what happened there and based on
that decide what's going on we don't do
any examples of map matching change
detection but we do use it in some
manner
anything else
thank you everyone
[Applause]